تمام التوفيق هذا على الاقل ما يمكن
الوقوف عنده خلال الايام الاخيره الاول
بدايه كانت اساسا بالخطاب الذي وصف
بالتصعيد الامين العام اتحاد العام
التونسي الشغل يوم السبت والذي وصافه
العديد من مراقبين بانه اتحاد عام التونسي
الشغل انتقل من مربع المسانده النقديه
للرئيس قيس سعيد الى مربع اخر وهو مربع
المعارضه السياسيه والاجتماعيه ايضا جبهه
الخلاص الوطني المعارضه تحدثت يوم امس على
لساني زعيم ها احمد نجيب الشامي اولا هي
قدمت حصيله سلبيه لفتره حكم الرئيس قيس
سعيد منذ انتخابه سنه 2019 هو ايضا خاصه
خلال تطبيق الاجراءات الاستثنائيه نحو سنه
ونصف وربما الانتباه في خطاب اجابه الخلاص
الوطني يوم امس هو تاكيد زعيمها احمد نجيب
الشابي ان المعارضه لسدد التوحد وانها قد
تلتقيط يوم السبت المقبل في مظاهره مشتركه
وذلك تحت شعار رحل في اشاره الى الرئيس
قيس عيد ايضا حركه النهضه اليوم عقدت
مؤتمر صحفي في الحقيقه خصصته لملفين اثنين
اولا الملف السياسي والثالثانا الملف
القضايا المرفوعه على القيادات حركه النظر
في الملف السياسي ايضا المتحدث الرسمي
باسم حركه النهضه انتقد كثيرا مسار 25
جويليه وايضا اعتبر ان الرئيس قيس سعيد
والصوت الحاليه هي تدفع البلاد نحو ما
وصفه بالانهيار الشامل ياتي كل هذه
المواقف في ماء الحمل الانتخابيه توفيق ما
زالت الى حدود هذه اللحظه متواصله تحول
تقريبا نحن بعنوان الذي يقول المراقبين
انها بطيئه وايضا انها فاتره وغياب
التنافس لكن هناك معطى جديد وهو الذي برز
اليوم من خلال البيان الذي اصدرته الهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات التي تقول ان
العديد من المقاطع الصور هو ايضا المقاطع
الفيديوهات المتداوله في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الهدف منه هو التشويه وترذيله
الحمله الانتخابيه وقالت انها ستتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه في صوره ما تبين ان
هناك بعض المترشحين ساهموا في هذه الحمله
طبعا موقف الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات جاء على خلفيه انتقادات كثيره
وجهها مراقبون وايضا فاعلون سياسيون لهذه
الحمله التي يتفقون بان بطيئه لكن يختلفون
في اسباب ذلك المعارضه تقول انه الاسباب
هو حاله النفور والعزوف من العمليه
الانتخابيه والمسار فيما تعتبر احزاب
المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات بان هذا فطور
هو امرا عادي لان الحمد خديجه ما زادت في
اسبوع هذا الثاني وربما تطوره خلال الايام
القادمه لكن ايضا يقولون ان النظام
الاسباب هذه الفطور هو غياب التمويل
العمومي في هذه الذي حرمها المترشحين من
موارد مليته هم من تطوير حملاتهم
الانتخابيه نعم طيب هل من وجوه باريزه في
هذه الحمله نردين
يعني الى حدود هذه اللحظه على الاقل
بالنسبه للاحزاب او المكونات مترشحه تقول
انه هناك وجوه علميه يعني سواء كان ذلك في
الاقتصاد او في التنميه او ايضا حتى
محامين من ذلك العميد السابق ابراهيم ابو
درباله ايضا هناك بعض بيضتين رجال اعمال
او المهتمين بقطاعات البحريه وايضا
المهتمين بالبيئه لكن في الاغلب وهو
بيحاسب الاحصاءات توفيق التي كانت قدمتها
العليا المستقله للانتخابات عند الاعلان
عن نتائج النهائيه للمقبولين في هذه
الانتخابات تقول ان النحو 40 في المياه من
المترشحينهم ينتمون الى قطاع الطلبه سواء
كانوا موظفين او اساتذه او اعوان هذا الى
جانب انه هناك عدد من العاطلين العمل
وهناك نسبه قليله طبعا من الاعمال الحره
عندما تتحدث عن الاعمال الحره اتحدث هنا
عن اطباء تتحدث عن المهندسين يتحدث عن
المحاميين وربما السبب في ذلك كما يقول
المراقبه همم توفيق يقولون بان القانون
انتخابه هو منع عن المترشحين للانتخابات
ان يمارس مهمته من اصليه خلال عمليه في
الانتخابات وبالتالي فان المحامي على سبيل
المثال لا يستطيعوا ان يكون محامي وفي نفس
الوقت عضو في البرلمان ولا ربما هذا ما
ساهم انه العديد من اصحاب المهن الحره
وطبعا الذين ينتمون الى بين نثرين ان نخبه
همم رفضوا او لم يشاركوا في هذه الحمله في
هذه الانتخابات نعم